All right, my deal,
follow the queen,
follow her all around.
All right, who's ready
for some wings?
Oh!
Come on, man.
Thanks, baby.
There's a queen right there.
You're the best, Mrs. H.
You guys are the best.
You rule, babe.
All right.
Dude, she is so great.
I am so lucky.
Speaking of lucky,
you know that girl I told
you about from my office?
Well, we went out for drinks
and then she took me back
to her place.
How was it?
Let's just say,
she's flexible.
Nice.
About butt stuff.
(all)
Oh!
Nice dude.
That takes me back,
takes me back.
A few weeks ago,
the kids were at
their Gran-gran's
and my wife was so down
to (bleep),
I mean, she's like,
practically begging me,
so I grab my wife's hair,
I bend her over
this credenza, right?
I'm like, so deep in (bleep),
I'm like, "Who's your husband?
Who's your husband?"
What's the matter
with you, man?
What?
That's your wife, man, okay?
That's not cool, okay?
We all went to college
with her,
we're friends.
That's, like, sick.
Sick.
Oh, I thought we were all kind
of sharing some stories.
You're a degenerate, man.
All right, all right,
anyway.
I had a little incident
with that waitress
over at Padigan's
the other night.
Oh, oh, hot Tracy?
Boom.
How did you do that?
She comes up to me
and she's like,
"Can you help me carry
this box into the office?"
Yeah, right?
What happened next?
I'll help you move your box.
Exactly, right?
So I go into the office
with her, next thing I know,
she's pulling on
my parking brake
like we're at the top
of Lombard Street.
Wow, wow, wow.
What about the tits?
As advertised.
Yes, yes!
It's always the best
when you don't expect it.
I remember there was
this girl in college,
and I totally thought
she was gonna put me
in the friend zone, right?
Well, we're hanging out,
all of a sudden,
top comes off,
she's riding me,
I'm rock (bleep) like a hammer.
And I'm like,
"I wanna marry this woman!"
I can't believe it's been
14 years.
That is so gross, Rob,
why are you doing this?
Nobody tells wife stories.
What are you, a psychopath?
Come on, man, she cooks us
Christmas dinner every year.
She's Mrs. Christmas to us.
Hope you guys don't mind.
I used four different cheeses.
You shouldn't have.
God bless you, honey.
All right,
you guys good on beers?
Yeah, we're great on beers.
You rock, Amy!
These nachos are insane,
by the way.
You know what else is insane?
We don't wanna hear it!
Jesus!
Shut your face.
This is a story about a woman
who I am totally
not married to, okay?
Go on.
All right.
Thank you.
We had just come out
of H&R Block,
and she's all turned on
'cause we're gonna get,
like, a sick return.
And she can buy this purse
she's been talking about
forever, right?
And she wants to bang
right in the back
of our pre-owned Subaru.
What are you doing, Rob?
What are you doing?
We know it's your wife, Rob.
Its just--
I feel like vomiting right now.
H&R Block?
You guys, I have to be able
to share stories
about the woman I love, okay?
I can't help it
that she's my wife, okay?
She inspires me.
She is my world.
I just thought 'cause
you're my friends, I could--
I could share some of our
romantic things with you.
All right, all right, man,
all right, all right.
Who's ready for the finale?
Chocolate chip cookies!
That could not
have come sooner.
You're the best, Mrs. H.
All right, if nobody needs
anything else,
honey, I'm gonna head upstairs.
Start lubing up
so you can blast
my dirt (bleep) with your thumb
while you lobster-hand me
in the (bleep), okay?
Seriously, I want you
to (bleep) that mud pit
'til I make a pig noise.
And then you can (bleep) on
my (bleep) while I call my mom.
Muah.
Okay. You guys are always
welcome here.
I guess I should eat up.